Adam Chambi: Hello, my name is Adam Chambi,
I am the product manager of the Google Cast software development group
And Cast extensions with OEM TV partners.
Sasha is here with me.
Sasha Brouter: I'm Sacha Brouter.
I'm the head of the Android TV team,
This is not my Twitter account.
So be gentle with whom you will communicate.
Who among you is here for the session,
It is among you in this room to order
Shadow and air conditioning?
Well, no hand raised.
Who are you here to get free devices?
very good,
Because there are no free devices.
If we talk to you a little
Today for the living room.
Adam will talk about Cast, and I'll talk shortly afterwards
About Android TV.
Here is Adam.
ADAM CHAMBI: Great
Well, we'll talk about building built-in experiences
For the living room.
Many of you may not think that the chances of success are great.
But let me tell you about a scenario
You may have passed it.
Millions of people will return to their homes tonight or tomorrow
They will turn on the TV.
If they are not lucky at all,
They may end up seeing between 5 to 7 loops
One of the worst serial reality exists.
The scary thing is that you often
You know the serial I'm talking about,
Or you have thought of three to four candidates.
Today we talk about experience
It should be easier for consumers
From running TV and struggling to watch something.
Today we are talking about our perception
For the living room, which Google Cast unites.
Google Cast is a technology that connects mobile phones
Owned by billions of people, with entertainment.
Whether they're extended devices like Chrome Cast,
Or built-in devices such as Android TV
Or what we'll talk about soon, Cast TV.
What these devices are doing is that they bring entertainment from the smallest
Screens that you own, to the most beautiful screens
In your home.
And sound to the best speakers you own.
More specifically, if that were not the case
A bit confusing for some, Google Cast is focused
On the mobile phone experience, take mobile web applications
And expand its content to screens and speakers
Larger.
So focus on this technology if you are a developer of mobile applications.
Android TV focuses on transferring the full capabilities of Android
And achieved in the form of a television, is controlled
Via a standard controller.
Sasha will tell you more about Android N updates
Within a few minutes.
The aim of the Cast experience for those who did not
They tell you, centered around the idea
Send button, which moves applications
Which you know and love to a large screen.
So when you press this button, the video will be transferred
To the screen.
Or when you press this button, it moves the music
To your speakers.
Millions of people like it.
Also amazing in this matter, is that we did
Enable thousands of applications.
To identify the apps we've enabled,
Visit the link: g.co/castapps
These are the same applications that users upload
And use them on their mobile phones, with Cast added.
The user does not have to do anything for applications.
For everyone in this room, this is often enough.
Where you can discover a way to make this experience
They work excellently, but there are many who
They did not attend an I / O conference or in different places
They view broadcasting technology as very far-fetched.
They see it as an HDMI link and they say
They do not want to connect any device to their devices.
Or they look at the experience of switching portals,
They say this is a disastrous recipe.
Because everything works before I press the input button.
But when you press the input button,
Something else happens. There is a possibility
One of four to do it wrong,
Due to the presence of four entrances in the television.
So we took this message seriously and worked with a team of
Vizio to build the first built-in TV with the Cast feature.
In particular, this one.
This beautiful screen of P series
Supports 4K transmission and Dolby image transmission.
This is the first built-in device to do this.
It is a wonderful beauty.
We can also see them in the protection mode.
What we did was make the same software development package
Used by developers capable of enabling television
From cast to Cast.
So once you hit the Cast button,
Instead of wishing you had been hit by the doorway,
It is an unmatched experience for the user.
Vizio applied this technique
On TVs as well as speakers and audio tapes.
We are also proud to announce today
About Google Cast TV.
Extending the spread of this technology to Toshiba, Philips and Magnavox products
And Polariod, which convey this technique
To millions of new users.
As for the developer community,
Now you can reach millions of end points,
Not only on Chrome Cast or Android TV,
But in a class of devices that integrate with the Cast feature alone,
Just Cast.
The wonderful thing about it is that it is
Same transmission feature you talked about in the first experiment.
Many, if not all, of these devices,
Another feature will include, an idea
It will be enabled by the Cast button.
That is, when you press this button,
The TV will run without the need for the user to do anything.
So, instead of having to find the controller and the TV,
Wishing to be connected to the right entrance, will be
Just click the Cast button to see what you love.
If such a user trip, draw the attention of a larger number of individuals
To the developer community.
But what is also proud of his announcement today
The new Google Cast software development group, this is our first major update
A few years ago.
It is based on many observations
Which tells us how Cast works.
One of the things you might think is--
I explained a very simple user experience model,
When you press a small button, the video moves from a small device
To a large device.
There are a lot of special cases, culprits and things
Which developers should think about in that experience.
Historically and honestly our software development group has made
Guided you to think about these things.
What we seek in our new group, which will be issued
In the next few weeks, is that we bear the burden
Apply all of Cast's user experience guidelines
Which are these side cases, better management
Practices.
In addition, we believe that we can significantly reduce the development period,
Not only provide it, but also provide
The right abstraction between what you develop and what you provide
Cast Software Development Group.
I'll explain it to you a bit.
For more information on all of this, visit our conversation at 9 am
Friday, if you do not wake up at nine
On Fridays, the conversation will be recorded.
I'll explain a bit about the Cast life cycle
If you do not attend Friday, it consists of four basic steps,
Three of them are realized almost all the time and one
Somewhat optional.
The first is discovery, try
Find out if I have a TV or Chromecast,
Do I have Android TV on my network?
This is an attempt to determine how to detect devices again.
The next step is to contact them.
And running the so-called receiver application.
The third step is control,
Because in the Cast model all the video and broadcast is directed
Directly from the cloud storage to the device
You send small messages back and forth.
Historically this has been confusing,
Because if it's done correctly, it's excellent.
If not done correctly, there is a great difficulty
In reconnecting, when you lose wireless connectivity,
Or if the user left and then returned,
Or when you change the network.
Some of these steps may be
Very complicated for the end-user experience.
We also made it complicated for the developer.
We have made you aware of each step
In this process.
So the life cycle of your applications is equal to the life cycle of our addition.
At first, it's simple
You may be invited to the Cast software development group and copy some scripts
Basic to your applications.
When you do this for the first time,
It's very easy.
However, if we make any modifications or updates,
It becomes very difficult for you to manage the two
Start making changes,
And also external factors that affect both
These options.
What we did in the new group,
Is that we have implemented a much better abstraction,
Where Cast transfers status,
It also provides default user interfaces for this very unique type of interaction model
Between the phone and a larger device.
More specifically, we are offering you two main areas
Versus case management and user experience.
In case management, you will now find what is called the Cast Context.
It is a single layer
Manages all phases of the situation, from discovery
Through calling and even launching the application
receiver.
We also offer an optional reconnection service,
For those who do not want you to deal
With an attempt to discover if it is still there
Chromecast or Cast TV is still connected to the network.
This is an optional service because some of you
Has already developed a lot in this area.
So you can choose to use it or not.
In terms of user experience, we now provide it
The user clicks the Cast button,
All the different Cast steps beyond that click,
So do not worry about callbacks
Try to discover the user's status,
Did he enter or exit this flow?
We also added for optional use
What we call the expanded controller
And microcontroller, which are part of our user experience guidelines.
In addition to our philosophy that
What is within the user experience guidelines, the group must provide.
We will see this in the next few slides.
For the new Cast button - and as you can see there are Android and iOS,
This new button is fully provided by our software development kit.
In an interview on Friday, we will talk
Add a Cast button
And all media broadcast details.
The software development group now fully supports drawing and management
All roots, including the highest level to see what
Which you should do with the background, then
The next stage (B) to describe the procedure
Which the user will do.
The third stage (C), a specific device selection,
And stage (D) it may be
Nothing happens on this device.
You do not have to worry about any of these situations at all.
You basically have a software method
To learn which color you should have the Cast button,
It is ready.
The next part we did was we built
Controllers are adjustable again.
So at the bottom of the screen, you'll see
A microcontroller, a microcontroller for play / pause
But you can already select any buttons
More useful to your application.
This always allows the user
Control the broadcast.
If you have a direct transfer application or music
I was very interested in moving to the next or the buttons of admiration
Or lack of admiration or the buttons of the heart and star,
This was the most important thing for your application,
You can put it in the microcontroller.
We also offer an optional extended controller,
Which applies the best practices of full screen control,
It allows us to similarly control
In the existing buttons.
Again, these two services are optional
On both Android and iOS, we can connect case transitions
To your controllers, if you have already done so
Invest enough time
In determining the user experience model that best suits your users.
On the other hand - I will use Android as an example,
We also provide small controllers, controllers
Extended, plus lock screen controllers.
These lock screen controllers also work with Android Wear watches.
So if you're literally not leaving your sofa,
You can not even pick up the remote control,
You can press the power button or pause your watch.
This is the last screen
It's for those of you who try to present the fact that Cast is now in their application,
Or for those who have changed the location of the Cast button slightly
In their app, or something similar, we offer you the Android-friendly notification feature
Which specifies the location of the Cast button.
You might think at first that this
It is in the interests of the Cast team, by mentioning Cast more.
But we could only have done it if it was really useful
Community of developers.
And what we found in applications that
We have experienced this concept as leading to longer sessions,
As well as greater commitment to the application itself.
We show this as an optional behavior style
You can call it on Android and iOS.
As to timing, we will launch these features
In the next few weeks.
The applications you see are fully experimental applications,
Where you will be able to go into the same script.
So by mid-June, you'll see the core software development package.
By the middle of the summer,
You will be able to access the controllers to be fully customizable.
We'll release iOS and Android versions first,
Then we add as layers the possibilities of the web sender,
As well as a new Web future
Compatible with all this.
All of the above is provided by the Cast application.
I will move here.
The cool thing about the Cast app is that you can not
Explore content, but you can control all of your devices.
As you can see, I have Cast TV as well as Chromecast.
The first device back
The Nexus player is Android TV.
To talk more about Android,
I'll leave talking to Sasha.
Sasha Brouter: Thank you.
Thanks Adam.
We'll talk a little bit about Android TV now.
I think this shows how Google looks at a room
Sit on it as one integrated system.
We combine other platforms into the integrated Cast system.
We also want to make Android TV
Basic end point in Cast.
We spent a lot of time making sure it was already.
One of the things Adam mentioned simply,
Is that since Cast is an experience based on mobile devices
In enabling the user to stream content to the TV,
With traditional Android TV control via remote control,
It is a comfortable experience.
Where you relax on the couch and pick up
Control from the table,
And starts displaying the content.
But with Cast in a compact way, what we see
Often in families, for example,
Children prefer to broadcast content from iPads
Or Android phones to your Android TV device,
While parents prefer to use the remote control.
So be nice on Android TV
Is the integration of different methods
To interact with television,
It also provides developers of user experience the ability to build new experiences
And distinctive on that television.
One of the things I want to clarify,
I will not spend much time with these marketing segments.
But what I want to explain well,
Is that Android TV is not something built for television
External and Android merged further.
It is already expanding the Android kernel framework
To make TV a top-class Android citizen.
This is important, because it is the only way that gives you as a developer
Ensuring that the APIs for Android will be
Always available to you to serve TV content.
Your application will not crash with updates from Android.
No, but with every new Android version.
You'll already get new features.
For those who have seen this meeting in the agenda of the Conference,
And thought to stay away from the sun by sitting here,
Or for those wishing to have free devices,
Here's a very quick summary.
What is Android TV really?
It's really a TV platform like Android has always been
Platform for mobile phones.
Android TV is a platform for TVs
Let you interact with them as a developer using all
The traditional tools you know through development
For Android on mobile phones.
The same software development package, the same developer tools,
You can activate a variety of device categories on Android TV.
With built-in smart TVs with Android TV,
We have seen great success worldwide for TV receivers
paid up.
Where cable TV, satellite or Internet TV service providers
Providing you with their own Android TV receivers.
So you can run your applications on them,
You also have the content of cable or satellite channels.
As our other classification of course, broadcast devices and gaming platforms,
Such as Nvidia Shield for example
Currently on the market.
These are excellent devices that allow users
Applications and games.
All on the same platform.
Let's talk a bit about what happened last year
With Android TV as well.
Integrated system grows.
We have more and more partners joining Android TV.
I think it's a very good story
To see partners who have already announced their support
In the first year of Android TV they are now back in support
And expand their Android TV models
For this year.
We are talking here about Sony, Sharp and Philips who are entering
New models to market.
But it is also nice to see new competitors in particular
With new areas like TCL, VESTEL, RCA or Beko
They launch Android TV devices in weeks
And the coming months.
We are also pleased to welcome a new partner
In the Android TV platform.
You see that orange logo there.
In fact we are very excited to announce
Become the new Android TV Partner
Xiaomi, with their first Android device
Their own in the US on Android TV.
Xiaomi will soon launch the Mi Box here in the United States,
It is the first Android TV product.
It is a very powerful device.
It supports 4K and HDR technology.
That means you get all the high-definition content from 4K technology
And accurately HDR content from Youtube, Netflix and others.
It supports all these features.
Comes with a stylish controller that supports voice commands
Bluetooth.
An additional accessory will also be available as a game controller,
You can enjoy Android TV games on your Mi Box.
To learn more about this, starting tomorrow
At 12:30, we will be hosting some people from Xiaomi.
So tomorrow at 12:30, Hyogo Bara will be from Xiaomi
With us at the Android TV corner there.
You will be able to experience the device,
And play it a bit.
Hyogo will also speak about the device.
You may have to take a personal photo with him
If you want to see the device, but it is up to you.
Let's move from the devices and let's talk a bit
About Content.
Because in the end, what matters to you on the TV.
Is content.
We're very excited to grow App Store on Android TV
During the past year.
We have a lot of new applications
Content and games on the platform.
In the coming weeks, we will see
Many of the newly arrived.
We are very happy to join ESPN
Native app on Android TV.
We also have additions from CNN, MTV, Disney and Comedy Central
And Crunchy Roll, all of which will launch their applications on Android TV during
In the coming weeks, or in fact some of them will be launched this week.
Increasing global content was also very important
Our.
For example, we are very pleased to launch Spotify
To apply to Android TV.
We also became our Deezer and others.
So, the integrated system grows
Also on the content level,
This is very gratifying
If, you already knew from Dave
This morning a little bit about
The new Android N has already explained to you
A new feature in his main speech, but I want to spend some time
Talking about new features related to Android N.
One of our main concerns was that when looking at Android N
Especially from a consumer perspective,
We thought it was very easy on Android TV
Disconnect your content.
If you see something,
The video was full-screen mode,
If you just want to find something
For content or search for
Other preferences you may have,
The content will be disconnected immediately.
Especially if you are an active user
I was moving fast
Among different types of content applications,
Such as moving between Live TV and Netflix or between Youtube and Hulu,
The system has not dealt with this well.
So one of the things we did was
Provide reasons as you know them
Of mobile phones, but in a manner suitable for remote controls.
Watch this video to see how it looks.
You know the traditional Android TV interface
Smooth content with easy storage.
If you are moving a lot between different applications,
If you are looking for a Youtube section here,
Then go back to Live TV to look for apps,
The "recent" option allows you to browse all applications
Which you recently used and move smoothly through the remote control.
If you do not like an option,
You can close it quickly,
Then you can go to the application
You want to see content on.
its very easy.
We spent a lot of time thinking about a model
Appropriate interaction if you have a remote control.
You do not want any special button,
You do not want anything complicated to use.
So we think we've come up with a good solution here,
It will be available for every device running Android TV.
Another very related topic
What I said earlier when you talked about losing communication
With content, or for you
As application developers or content providers,
Loss of communication with the user at the moment to decide
He wanted to find something.
One of the things we wanted to invest in
Were watching more than one source of content,
On one screen.
So we have a picture style inside an image,
Which will enable you to stay connected
Including what you were watching during your search
About new content.
Watch this video to see how this looks.
that's cool.
If we have converted all our offers to videos,
Because presentations always fail.
If next year, we will provide offline status for Youtube.
For example, you see Live TV,
And hear something interesting to you.
For example here, report
For a game just released on Android,
Think that this is interesting,
Why do not I try to find her?
The search opens,
And looking using voice search for "PAC-MAN", you find that
You can install and play them on your Android TV device
You have.
But throughout this time, content continues to display.
You have not been disconnected from what you see,
We believe this is a very important experience.
Especially as content increases
You are on the podium.
What we have allowed you to do as developers
The picture-in-picture feature is enabled
In your applications.
You can basically install the video in a section.
You can also add a special button
To the media controllers in the control bar, if you select this,
Easily move to an image-in-picture style
For devices that do not contain
Button dedicated to it.
There are some devices such as smart TVs,
Already contains a picture-in-picture button,
But we wanted the interface design
Make you use all standard controllers
Able to activate this experience.
You can activate the picture-in-picture mode
Easily within your application, just add
This feature to your application files.
There is an activity in changing the picture-in-picture style.
All you need is to apply it and be ready.
Something else we've been working on from the start,
Is to support traditional TV functions.
I know we all love apps and games,
We like to have as many applications as possible on TVs.
But still a large proportion of watching TV at home
For traditional TV.
So from the beginning of Android TV
Since Android L, we've implemented something
The TV entrance frame is called.
Which deals with things like switching HDMI inputs,
Or control the cable TV cable.
Applications also have the ability to deploy channels through this interface.
In version L, it was a simple change in channels,
Key channel data, and software directory.
We've expanded this on Android M by adding capabilities
Skip time.
So if your content is on a live channel,
You can take advantage of time skipping.
On Android M, we're adding sign-ups,
So, you'll become a content provider on your channel
To offer easy recording capabilities
The user also knows it from any old recording device.
Watch this video to see how it looks.
This is a simple receiver.
This is as a device with a MOLV receiver.
You can browse the directory, you know all of it.
By the way, these are geometric designs for the user experience.
I struggled so much to introduce them to you.
So I mean I did not ask her from our user experience design expert.
If this is not the final version we will launch,
However, we will provide an update to the Live Channels app
In the Play Store for apps.
You can see all standard things
Such as registration and scheduling management.
You can delete and schedule registrations,
Just as you would in any traditional recording device.
As a content provider, you can
Choose to provide these experiences.
Here is an example of how sub-features work as an accelerator
The display returns the display.
We also have additional components for this in our media controllers.
So it's very straightforward and you can try it
As part of the Android software development package presentation.
As I mentioned earlier, we provide a standard set
Such as scheduling and starting and stopping the registry
And display recordings including key channel data.
This can be managed from the TV application.
At Google, we provide a single TV app,
It is available on NVIDIA Shield, Nexus player and others,
Which is the application of direct channels.
Some TV manufacturers offer their own application,
But they all support the TV front frame.
As a developer,
If you want to provide content on live channels
Make them recordable,
You can add this by applying a session session class
New.
This is explained as part of the documentation documentation for the software development kit
For Android N.
Also from the things we'll show a trial version with,
Is that we will provide support for connecting an external USB mulch
As an open source model, where you can
Connect USB mulph and antenna synthesizer
With your Nexus player, for example.
The content will go directly to your Nexus player
You can try recording and everything you mentioned
With regard to broadcasting management.
We will provide this as an open source demo
As part of the Direct Channels application.
Another very important topic for us in Android N,
Is to support HDR, or a high-level dynamic property properly,
As you know, with the spread of new TVs that support ultra-clear images
HDR has become an important topic.
They give the possibility of viewing
Wide range of colors, with natural color schemes
Right.
One of the problems we encountered
It provides several HDR standards
Different.
For example, you have HDR 10 and Dolby Vision,
And Hybrid Log-Gamma.
For both developer and consumer,
This is confusing.
Because how will I know which criterion I support?
If I have a content app I wanted to introduce
Beautiful 4K content in HDR format,
What criteria should I use?
How do I know what the device supports?
On Android N, we add new APIs that support HDR,
We process two cases:
The first is the case of hardware manufacturers,
So they can add
Their HDR adapter is well connected to the system and send signals to it,
And advertising that they support HDR standards.
As for content developers, for example Netflix,
They can query the system and see
On the standards supported by the device,
Then they choose the way they want to broadcast.
This may be one of the criteria,
Such as their broadcast streams for this device,
Or they can make a decision.
This device does not support the HDR center that I need,
So I will be broadcasting 4K with its initial image.
We also added APIs to HDR capabilities
So that applications can query possibilities
this device.
There are some important things here.
That the converter's potential would be vulnerable,
We have some requirements for this purpose.
The HDR requires 10 HEVC adapters to support,
The Dolby Vision requires a special HEVC switch
The hybrid log gamma requires VP9 version 2.
By the way, this is the version that Youtube announced
At the beginning of this year they will support HDR and its jurisprudence.
Another important topic, especially
In the I / O Developers Conference, it is a Leanback library.
The Leanback Library is our toolkit for enabling application development
Extremely easy on Android TV.
If you're familiar with developing Android apps
On cell phones, tablets, or others,
With the Leanback Support Library,
We give you a set of tools to easily move your application
From mobile phone to big screen.
Over the past year, we've seen a lot of developers
They use our toolkit, and we get a lot of notes.
There were some missing things.
There were cases of use that we did not envision
Initially.
And for a while we listened, and we will
Provide an update to the Leanback library very soon.
It is almost in the final stage of completion.
For example, we add support for custom segments
In browsing fragmentation.
Fragmentation browsing is one of the things you allow
You can view multiple lists of content in your app
Very easily.
But we have a strict trend in this regard.
We had one idea basically about how it should look.
And we get a lot of feedback that supports the idea of browsing itself
Good, but they want in their applications
To be a little different.
Where they wanted different key data
Or a different arrangement.
And build a dedicated segmentation
Inside the browser fragmentation will greatly help,
Without having to reinvent the wheel.
We also greatly improved the media player
To support the ad hoc procedures.
We get the details of media procedures specifically,
If you have an app with great content
Needs to display many of the main data of the content
And interacting with it during playback, this will help you.
We also made brands easier.
Many of the notes that we received included
If you use the Leanback library as a default library to build your application,
It will be a little difficult to enter your brand in it,
And make your app slightly different from other applications.
We made some modifications to allow you to enter your tag easily,
Without having to re-invent and build everything
Yourself again.
For this, this was just a high-level thriller
For what is happening here.
There is another session this week, and we will hear later those meetings
Which delves deeply into the Leanback Library and its operations
Internal.
So if you're a developer who wants to develop apps for Android TV,
It will be a very wonderful session for you.
Three of our developers will talk about a range of usage cases
They will explain some of these news
And how Leanback actually works
Inside Android TV.
If with all these new things, how can you
To deal with it?
As you heard in the main talk, the pilot version of the developers
Of Android N is already available.
So you can download it now.
You have to start with that.
All Android TV features are included as part of a development group
Android standard software.
There is nothing special about television,
But only Android.
So, if you download the beta version of developers,
The Leanback Library will be included,
As well as all the new TV features.
We also updated the documentation files
And some application models as part of it.
We also got some feedback regarding the TV simulator
Its content was very bad,
The reviews were fair, because
Because his performance was already very bad.
We updated it a bit,
We think it is much better now.
It has become usable as a standard development tool.
You do not have to use the devices anymore.
For those who have a Nexus Player of yours,
You can register or upload a demo version of the developers
Android N.
You can download the image in Flash,
Or register for a copy that comes directly to the device from the Internet.
Another important thing, we have a lot of
Sessions that give more details than the overview
At this meeting.
If you are interested, especially if you are
You're working on media streaming apps, join the XO Player session
Valid for mobile phones and TVs today.
We have office hours for the living room,
For Cast and Android TV tomorrow at 10pm,
As for the talk I mentioned a little while ago it is at three o'clock in the afternoon
About diving deep into Leanback's support library.
At nine o'clock I think it's time to talk and explain
Cast Software Development Group.
I and Jay will talk on Friday at 11
About moving live content to Android TV,
In much more detail than this session.
At two o'clock on Friday there is a wonderful meeting,
If you have a mobile phone application you wonder
About how he was transferred to television.
How does the transfer actually take place?
What are best practices?
What is the easiest way?
Then this will be a wonderful meeting to prepare for.
As we have support communities,
And developer communities, you can see links here.
So I think it's time for questions.
I think we have microphones here somewhere
If there are any questions.
Supposed to be on both sides.
I see one there, the other on the other.
So, if you have any question, get up and ask the question.
If there are no questions, I do not mind.
ADAM CHAMBI: For your information, our trial box is a distance away
About 100 yards from here, we'll be there
For long times of day, tomorrow and Friday.
Audience: Hello, I have a question.
Can you hear me?
In fact all this talk about the sitting room and about
Google Cast and Android TV.
I am a former education technician in fact,
I wonder about interactive content streaming
To the smart panels in the rows.
Do you support formats other than video and audio?
For broadcast?
ADAM CHAMBI: I can answer.
Can those who leave
Have a little rest for a second?
The main factor of the interaction or the main factor of the class
It can be presented in two different ways.
If you have a mobile app that wants to show something
On the big screen, as a video or voting content
Of different students in the class,
The Cast model is so excellent.
You can continue the discussion on Friday,
Where we can talk a little more about it.
Jaguar: I'm talking about custom content.
For example HTML5 or Flash.
Adam Chambi: We currently support Cast
HTML5 player and some formats
Different media.
I will be happy to talk to you after the hearing
More specifically about it.
I'll ask you out immediately.
Audience: App Store in Android TV is a bit bad.
My application is buried at the bottom of the menu
There is no way people can download it,
Because you have to continue to scroll to the right,
No one will move more than 3 or 4
Or up to 5 apps at the bottom of the list.
Because you are using the Leanback Library for the App Store as well
I think so.
Will there be any improvement in that?
To discover my application?
Sasha Brouter: I mean, now and while the application store is full
With more and more applications, it's a little bit like
With a mobile phone, right?
You can not expect millions of apps
Each application should be on the first page.
No one scrolls through millions of apps,
So we focus more on showing the ratings more,
You will do some work on distinctive applications,
As well as improved search.
But so far it is only a passing model with thousands of applications
In the store, so no model will be back.
What we are trying to do soon
Is to try to find a model based on classifications,
To search within different types of applications is easier
For the user.
Then the discovery will be by browsing labels
Depending on who wants to search for it
A little easier.
Audience: Awesome
Is there a way to distinguish applications that are not Netflix
Like all large applications, maybe with some supervision
We try to raise small applications
There?
Sasha Brouter: We have guidance if you look at
android.com/tv, we have a way to example guidelines
The user experience must be achieved to take the application into account in the discrimination.
It also depends on the region
Where your application is available, what is its content,
And your competition.
We can always distinguish or market
Very small number of applications.
So we are working more on mobility according to the classification,
More discovery options are available at the Andriond TV application store
And research.
Audience: Great, thanks.
Sasha Brouter: Thank you very much.